bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
pour terminer cette semaine spéciale
consacrée aux un an de la nouvelle
Assemblée on va vous parler ce soir d'un
formidable podcast le vôtre Anne
souhaite mon bonsoir et merci d'être de
notre grand témoin ce soir vous êtes
journaliste à France Inter et vous venez
de signer député au pluriel c'est un
podcast pas comme les autres on va le
voir qui nous plonge au cœur de la vie
parlementaire 5 députés un des messages
vocaux via le réseau WhatsApp à
l'arrivée ça donne une chronique à la
fois intime politique et extrêmement
pédagogique aussi bien sur la forme que
sur le fond on en parle ensemble dans la
deuxième partie mais on commence ce soir
par cette question faut-il arrêter de
prendre l'avion face à l'urgence
climatique l'ingénieur Jean-Marc
Jancovici a créé la polémique en
proposant de nous limiter à quatre vols
durant toute notre vie Emmanuel Macron
n'est pas sur la même longueur d'onde
lui parie sur l'avion vert
100% biocarburant d'ici seulement 10 ans
alors quel est le bon équilibre l'avion
peut-il continuer à faire rêver nos
enfants grands débat dans un instant
avec mes invités avant de retrouver nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
dans Bourbon Express ce soir c'est
députés qui veulent revenir sur la
réserve parlementaire et si et bien
c'était son grand retour pas si sûr on
verra ça voilà pour le programme vous me
suivez un traitement ça vous regarde
c'est parti
[Musique]
il est devenu le symbole du transport
polluant par excellence et la cible des
activistes pour le climat l'avion a-t-il
encore de l'avenir dans notre pays oui
trois fois oui à répéter Emmanuel Macron
sur tous les tons aujourd'hui chez
Safran le président vient de faire toute
une série d'annonces pour soutenir
l'avion du futur à zéro émission alors
limitation ou technoolution bonsoir
Michel polaco et merci d'être là vous
êtes un grand journaliste spécialiste de
l'aéronautique chroniqueur aujourd'hui à
aéro-morning ancien pilote aussi je
crois toujours pilote toujours pilote
félicitations vous débattez ce soir avec
Jean-Paul iadek bonsoir merci à vous
vous êtes ingénieur ancien président du
BEA le bureau français d'enquête et
d'analyses pour la sécurité aérienne et
membre de l'Académie de l'Air et de
l'Espace bonsoir Flora gaybahi ravi de
vous retrouver qu'aux présidente de
coalition c'est une société qui
accompagne les entreprises dans leur
transition écologique vous êtes
l'autrice du syndrome de la fourmi aux
éditions de l'Observatoire on en avait
parlé il y a quelques semaines enfin
bonsoir Nathan de verre ravi de vous
retrouver vous êtes écrivain vous
enseigner la philosophie à Bordeaux ce
débat sur les limites sur les
renoncements face aux réchauffement
climatique il est aussi philosophique et
donc ça nous intéresse de vous entendre
Anne souhaite-moi la citoyenne que vous
êtes je suis sur un petit idée de la
question n'hésitez pas à interroger nos
invités on commence par planter le décor
comme chaque soir il a deux secondes le
chrono de Blacko c'est parti
allez je me retourne comme chaque soir
pour vous accueillir du haut de votre
estrade mon cher Stéphane bonsoir à vous
bonsoir miam bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors
l'avion vous savez que il est
régulièrement montré du doigt comme
étant le moyen de transport le plus loin
ou un des plus polluants monde au point
que si on veut vraiment faire baisser
les émissions de CO2 certains proposent
des solutions radicales souvenez-vous
c’était en 2019 et Greta Thunberg avait
décidé d'aller à New York en bateau donc
15 jours de traverser au lieu de 8
heures de vol donc malgré tout ce petit
coup d'éclat médiatique n'a pas vraiment
eu un effet d'entraînement puisque quand
on regarde les chiffres de
l'aéronautique aujourd'hui voyez on voit
que d'une part après la crise du covid
qui avait fait baisser le nombre de vols
et bien le trafic est reparti et puis ça
risque pas de s'arrêter en tout cas
selon les prévisions parce que quand on
voit Airbus il nous disent que dans 20
ans il devrait construire sans doute
deux fois plus d'avions alors les
fabricants d'avion eux ils essaient
d'être rassurants ils nous disent mais
vous rassurez-vous grâce au progrès de
la science les avions du futur seront
beaucoup moins polluants et on pourra
permet de voler sans pollués et c'est
sur ce point que Jean-Marc Jancovici
mais pas du tout d'accord parce que
selon lui aucun progrès technique n'est
en mesure de régler ce problème on
l'écoute aujourd'hui l'avion c'est 8% du
pétrole mondial et l'avion est né avec
le pétrole et Morat avec le pétrole
d'accord donc il y a pas de solution
technique à l'échelle comme il n'y a pas
de solution technique si on part de ce
postulat donc inévitablement il faudra
diminuer le nombre de vols à l'avenir et
donc là il y a deux solutions soit on le
fait par les prix c'est à dire qu'on
augmente le prix de l'avion donc seul
les riches peuvent voler et comme il y a
pas beaucoup de riches mais forcément on
pollue moins soit c'est la solution de
jean-colissi on fixe un quota on
interdit aux riches comme aux pauvres de
voler plus de 4 fois par an alors cette
proposition évidemment elle a fait
beaucoup réagir je sais pas si elle a
toujours été bien comprise d'ailleurs et
notamment le patron d'Airbus qui
explique que non il faut avoir confiance
en la science pour l'instant c'est vrai
on a pas de solution mais on va en
trouver on l'écoute
ça me rappelle lors de Kelvin qui était
un grand mathématicien et physicien qui
a dit en 1895 faire voler des objets
plus lourds que l'air et physiquement
impossible
et en 1903 les frères right ont fait
voler leur avion donc voilà il faut pas
regarder que dans le rétroviseur il faut
regarder devant et on a les solutions
pour des carboner l'aviation alors qui a
raison Jean-Côme ici ou fonderie alors
on va demander à un tiers d'arbitré qui
est l'ADEME qui l'autorisation par
l'agence sur la transition écologique en
France voilà donc qui étudier le dossier
du transport aérien et qui donne plutôt
raison agent colline si en disant il y a
pas de solution technique suffisante il
faudra nécessairement sur votre objectif
limiter le nombre de vols d'ailleurs le
gouvernement vous savez a commencé à le
faire il a interdit les vols sur des
distances qui peuvent se faire entrer en
moins de 2h30 ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
plus de Paris Bordeaux plus de Paris
Nantes plus de Paris Lyon en avion cela
dit on oppose deux solutions qui sont
pas non plus qui peuvent être
complémentaires c'est à dire que on peut
quand même modérer le nombre de vols et
en même temps développer les nouvelles
solutions techniques des avions plus
légers comme on l'a déjà fait qui
consomment le biocarburant qui est moins
polluent et puis un peu plus long terme
l'hydrogène qui serait carrément le zéro
émission donc en tout cas en l'état des
choses une chose est sûre c'est que la
France n'a pas l'intention de perdre sa
position de leader dans l'aéronautique
et donc ce matin le président Macron
était chez Safran qui fabrique des
moteurs pour annoncer l'idée qu'on
allait renforcer le budget de la
recherche donc au total plus 750
millions pour essayer de trouver le
fameux avion 0 émission mais est-ce
qu'on va le trouver dans combien de
temps alors là il y a des bas merci
beaucoup Stéphane de ce débat justement
lancer par Jean-Marc Jancovici Michel
polako qu'est-ce qu'il dit deux vols
pour découvrir le monde quand on est
jeune deux vols pour partir en vacances
quand on est vieux le reste du temps on
prend le train même si ça prend parfois
plusieurs jours ça fait partie de
l'aventure qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors quand Jean-Marc jean-kevinci dit
l'avion est né avec le carburant avec le
fioul avec le pétrole imourec le pétrole
il oublie que la locomotive à vapeur est
donc le train est né avec la vapeur et
qu'il n'est pas mort avec la vapeur
comme quoi voyez des gens très
intelligents peuvent dire de
monstrueuses il est bien évident que
tout cela n'a absolument aucun sens on
peut pas raisonner comme ça d'abord
imaginons tout simplement qu'on décide
d'autoriser comme ça arbitrairement
certains citoyens avaient les quatre
fois dans leur vie puis d'autres ils
auraient pas envie de voler du tout
c'est leur droit il y en a pas mal aussi
il dit que c'est mieux que d'augmenter
les prix parce que sinon l'avion à terme
deviendrait un transport d'ultra riche
oui un transport du travail moi il y
aura d'avion moins il y aura de gens qui
voleront moins on pourra fabriquer
d'avions et donc plus les avions seront
chers et plus les billets sont chers et
donc plus ce sera réservé une élite donc
c'est bien évident si vous voulez Airbus
par exemple vont en gros on va dire 700
800 avions par an à ce prix là enfin
avec ce nombre là ils arrivent à des
prix qui sont intéressants pour les
compagnies et qui sur lesquels débouche
le prix du billet et tout le système de
transport à rien qui fonctionne derrière
les aéroports le contrôle aérien etc si
vous réduisez la masse de départ c'est
si vous dites bon bah Airbus a plus le
droit de fabriquer que 50 avions par an
mais ils mettent la clé sous la porte
c'est pas la peine ils pourront jamais
faire
marcheristes on peut dire ça comme ça je
suis techno solutionniste et je suis
surtout partisan d'un certain bon sens
et de l'abandon d'idéologie qui en soi
ne peuvent pas déboucher sur des vraies
solutions écologiques alors il y a quand
même cette idée d'un pic pétrolier
Jean-Paul tropadec on va le franchir en
2030 c'est ce que dit Jean covicie il y
aura pas de quoi de toute façon assurer
quatre vols dans une vie de terrien une
fois qu'on aura plus de pétrole il a
tort ce constat il faut ce constat est
faux parce qu'il y a des alternatives à
l'utilisation du kérosène tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui extrait du sous-sol et ces
alternatives elles sont connues les
solutions existent il va falloir les
mettre en oeuvre et c'est là le
challenge le challenge ça va être de
développer les carburants alternatifs
alors on parle de biocarburant mais qui
ne pourront probablement pas satisfaire
l'ensemble des besoins de l'aviation et
au de ça on parle de
if you le c'est-à-dire en fait de
carburants de synthèse dont la
technologie existe on va y revenir
un plan de mise en oeuvre une feuille de
route si vous voulez qui vise à ce qu'en
2050 laviation soit neutre et totalement
décarbonée 2050 2050 ça sera suffisant
comme timing ou d'ici là pour respecter
les accords de Paris il va falloir
changer nos comportements je crois qu'il
y a un petit biais dans ce débat en fait
le débat pro ou anti-avion c'est
certainement pas un débat moral c'est
juste le respect des de contraintes
physiques de limite planétaire en fait
c'est comme si là on avait tous que je
nous souhaite pas un cancer du poumon et
qu'on débattait sur est-ce qu'on peut
continuer à fumer ou est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on arrête bon bah on peut continuer
si on décide de d'aller plus rapidement
vers vers la fin quoi mais on aurait
plutôt intérêt à arrêter et ben en fait
avec l'avion c'est pareil je pense que
il faut juste faire un rappel utile qui
est que aujourd'hui un Français moyen
enfin un français en moyenne
émet 9 à 11 tonnes de CO2 par an et pour
respecter les accords de Paris on
devrait être individuellement à deux
tonnes donc pour passer de 9 à 11 tonnes
à 2 tonnes on doit faire un régime de
nos émissions carbone assez drastiques
et pour info on prend souvent l'exemple
du Paris-New York un Paris New York
c'est déjà une un peu plus d'une tonne
aller-retour donc en fait en ouais en un
ou deux long courrier par an on épuise
son son quota annuel donc en fait ça
c'est juste la donnée c'est juste la
donnée physique et scientifique mais
quand on regarde les transports en
France c'est vrai ce que vous dites de
toute façon l'avion c'est le plus
polluant de tous les transports sur le
sur le marché de l'usager classique non
entre le train la voiture alors la
voiture il y en a beaucoup plus mais un
avion plus qu'une voiture de
l'électricité en majorité et souvent
avec du diesel vous êtes d'accord
l'électricité qui est utilisée par notre
en France elle est à moitié nucléaire
puisqu'on a à peu près 50% de production
nucléaire et l'autre moitié elle est
faite avec des énergies fossiles donc le
train fonctionne à moitié avec du gaz et
du Pétrole bon et c'est comme ça pour à
peu près tous les moyens de transport le
toute la marine toute la marine marine
de commerce marine militaire etc
fonctionne avec du pétrole tous les
moyens de transport sur cette planète
c'est 3% du du CES 3% des rejets de CO2
dans l'atmosphère ça vous parlez de
l'avion à l'échelle mondiale on a
regardé les chiffres 3% par rapport aux
transports donc si vous voulez
qu'on comprenne l'avion en France en
France dans le monde c'est aussi en
France ça correspond à 39
j'ai regardé pour comparer
déjà ce débat sur au fond les compromis
qu'on nous demande de faire les
renoncements parce que c'est un débat
sur les renoncements qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez ça ça demande de quoi
d'accompagner les mentalités ou au
contraire c'est c'est un mauvais débat
je pense sans grandiloquence que
derrière la question de l'aviation se
pose la question qui sera la question la
plus importante en philosophie politique
du 21e siècle à savoir que la
catastrophe climatique est une crise
scientifique au même titre d'ailleurs
que l'épidémie de coronavirus et le
siècle auquel on va être confronté est
un siècle où les grandes questions
politiques seront des questions
scientifiques ça ça pose une question
énorme c'est que des citoyens entre
guillemets normaux comme moi par exemple
on a aucune compétence scientifique ni
climatique ni aéronautique donc dans ce
cas là on pourrait estimer que nous
n'avons pas notre avis à donner et que
il faut juste appliquer mécaniquement
des solutions entre guillemets
scientifiques et donc là ça pose une
question démocratique derrière
l'aviation se pose la question de savoir
si au nom d'une d'un problème
scientifique qui est encore une fois est
absolument légitime si on peut sacrifier
des principes politiques on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure la liberté de
se déplacer l'aviation c'est pas
seulement la liberté de se déplacer ça a
été un moment majeur dans l'introduction
des sociétés ouvertes et par rapport aux
sociétés fermées ça a été aussi en
littérature par exemple et pas que en
littérature mais l'invention de
l'humanisme politique qui est inventé
par Saint-Exupéry dentaire des hommes et
vol de nuit qui sont des textes
d'aviateurs et c'est évidemment pas une
coïncidence il y a quelque chose de très
profond et c'est très concrètement par
exemple la question de prendre quatre
vols par an c'est la question aussi de
la binationalité qu'il y ait dans un
pays des binationaux qui est envie de
retourner dans une vie dans une vie dans
une vie chaque fois vous dites Stéphane
avait dit ça aussi
pour découvrir le monde on va dire quand
on est jeune et puis deux pour faire
encore quelques voyages pour partir en
vacances après 40 ans et donc prenez
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui serait
binational qui aurait de la famille dans
un pays très lointain sur un autre
continent et qui aurait une limitation
pour pouvoir s'y rendre ou qui devrait
le faire en culpabilisant ou qui devrait
le faire beaucoup moins long souvent et
bien ça évidemment le risque moi que j'y
vois c'est absolument pas une défense de
l'aviation au sens technique c'est une
défense des sociétés ouvertes c'est une
défense et c'est une critique une peur
d'en revenir à une société de
l'enracinement du repli sur soi de la
fermeture et à mon avis c'est ça aussi
qui c'est la fin du métissage pour vous
s'il y a plus d'avion
encore une fois c'est pas l'avion en
tant que tel mais c'est je dirais le la
révolution culturelle philosophique
politique dont l'avion a été l'un des
vecteurs majeurs c'est aussi la remise
en cause de tous les territoires
d'outre-mer n'oublions pas que tous les
territoires d'outre-mer ne sont reliés à
la France à la métropole que par l'avion
mais allons expliquer aux Antillais par
exemple que dorénavant ils ne pourront
plus prendre l'avion que quatre fois
dans toute leur vie je pense qu'on peut
s'attendre à un centre de réaction et ça
serait je pense une coupure très
profonde entre la France et ses
territoires qui a des solutions pour
retrouver des compromis et en même temps
travailler sur l'avion vers au travers
très rapidement investir et en même
temps peut-être changer un peu les
comportements sans aller jusqu'à
j'encovici il y a des lois qui ont été
votées ici à l'Assemblée la loi climat
qui voulait interdire les petites lignes
aériennes à moins de 4 heures de ça pas
été exactement ça qui a été appliqué oui
total de nos je suis très tout à fait
d'accord avec avec ce que vous avez dit
mais entre le rep total de nos
civilisations où on pourrait plus passer
d'un continent à l'autre et l'état des
choses actuelles où vous avez un vol
pour Londres depuis Paris qui est alors
qu'il y a un train qui dure deux heures
pour y aller qui coûte 10 euros tandis
que le train coûte 200 euros il y a
quand même un monde entre les deux et en
fait le problème c'est que oui moi aussi
ça me vous croyait vraiment que quand on
défend une vision écologique de la
société on n'a pas nous aussi envie
d'aller prendre un avion pour 10 euros
pour aller voyager parcourir le monde et
quand on regarde l'application de la
Convention citoyenne pour le climat
évidemment ne sont pas voilà les vols à
moins de 4 heures en alternative au
train qui ont été le 2h30 seulement
voilà le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
entre la technosolution à savoir avoir
un vol à hydrogène qui qui a une
empreinte carbone neutre ou relativement
négative et laisser le néolibéralisme
libéré le trafic aérien comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui il y a quand même un gap
et ce gap là il est politique et il y a
par exemple le passe train en Europe qui
permettrait de payer un tarif unique via
les impôts annuels par an pour pouvoir
prendre le train de manière illimitée en
France et en Europe sorte de ticket
illimité du train le tarif unique on
appelle ça à tarif unique il y a l'idée
de pas avoir de vol au-delà de 2h30 mais
plutôt de 4 5 6 heures dès que c'est
possible de prendre le train
de considérer ça soviétique de ne pas
être libéral Michel les compagnies
aériennes on se souvient de voilà ils
ont pas décollé les avions pendant la
crise covid c'est la pire crise de leur
histoire les différents états la France
a beaucoup aidé l'aérien mais il y avait
aussi cette demande de contrepartie
c'est à dire peut-être travailler sur
des carburants moins polluants qui a été
obtenu alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
depuis les avionneurs c'est la seule
profession si je puis dire en englobant
l'ensemble de cette industrie c'est la
seule profession qui a pris un
engagement très clair
français en 2050 nous serons neutres ça
veut pas dire qu'on sera pas avant enfin
qu'ils ne sont pas avant ça veut dire en
2050 nous serons neutres ça veut dire
qu'ils ont mis en route toute la machine
industrielle de recherche etc pour
trouver essayer de trouver des pistes
des solutions
mais aujourd'hui
la semaine prochaine allez au salon du
Bourget vous allez voir la démonstration
faramineuse de tout ce qui est en route
toutes ces centaines de petites
aujourd'hui et ils veulent des avions
qui consomment moins mais le problème
c'est le carburant
ce qui pollue c'est le carburant l'avion
l'avion éventuellement on peut dire
qu'il fait du bruit
c'est le carburant on le taxe pour des
raisons qui qui n'ont rien à voir qui
sont extrêmement avec le réchauffement
réponse sur le fait que monsieur a dit
que j'étais soviétique c'est très
pertinent ce que vous avez dit parce que
c'est exactement le problème des de la
vision du 20e siècle qui empêche la
transition écologique d'advenir c'est à
dire que dès qu'on s'attaque aux
libertés on a une vision binaire qui est
une vision d'un autre siècle où on
oppose liberté et états
interventionniste soviétique la Chine
pas de liberté le problème monsieur
c'est que la liberté au sens
philosophique du terme c'est quand même
qu'elle s'arrête celle des uns s'arrête
là où démarre celle des autres et
aujourd'hui quand il y a 10% de
l'humanité qui prend l'avion et qui
corrompt les chances de vivre des 100%
de l'humanité dans les années à venir
alors nous ne sommes pas dans une
démarche libérale
moi je suis profondément libérale au
sens philosophique du terme et vous
savez la liberté d'aisance
le gros problème c'est que nos
gouvernants ils ont été éduqués au 20e
siècle et donc ils ont une vision
binaire des choses qui est tout à fait
obsolète et Monsieur les personnes comme
vous ferez mieux de laisser la place aux
personnes comme nous qui comprenons les
enjeux du réchauffement climatique
allez je vais pas tarder à m'en aller
mais personne ne veut que vous en alliez
vous restez vous êtes très bien ici
on pourrait parfaite santé Nathan de
verre moi je ne suis pas en désaccord
avec vous sur ce point et autant je
défends les valeurs culturelles et
Politico culturelles dont j'estime que
l'avion a été un des vecteur autant je
peux avoir un regard très critique sur
l'utopie de l'aviation celle des années
80 qui avait au moins me semble-t-il
deux angles morts c'est que c'était
absolument inégalitaire même si quand
même toute l'histoire de l'aviation
c'est la baisse des tarifs quand il y a
quelques années il y avait eu le record
du Paris-New York le moins cher alors
c'est pas un but dans la vie
nécessairement de découvrir New York
mais ça permet à des gens qui
nourrissent jamais pu aller à New York
par exemple dans les années 80 et qui
peuvent aujourd'hui y aller ça vous
voyez bon mais il y a cet angle mort
inégalitaire et il y a l'angle mort de
c'est une mondialisation qui est
totalement aveugle au monde c'est les
clubs de vacances etc ça on est on est
d'accord mais moi il y a quelque chose
qui me quand même qui m'interpelle c'est
que quand on parle les grands facteurs
de pollution qui existent aujourd'hui on
parle énormément de l'avion on parlait
énormément des transports mais par
exemple il y a un facteur de pollution
qui est pourtant très important et même
selon certaines études au moins aussi
important que l'avion voire plus qui est
la pollution numérique et je m'étonne de
ce que on en parle aussi peu par exemple
souvent quand il y a une personnalité
écologique en une demande si elle prend
l'avion et la personnalité en question
dit non moi je ne prends pas l'avion je
le prendrai peu etc en revanche on ne
l'a culpabilise jamais sur l'usage
massif qui est fait des réseaux sociaux
et très souvent d'ailleurs il y a des
personnalités écologiques très très
importantes qui sont en permanence en
train de Twitter de mettre des vidéos
souvent sur une certaine demande
d'envoyer des mails les
usines qui recrent qui récoltent et qui
voilà qui
rassemble des données collectées par des
géants du numérique qui sont extrêmement
consommatrices et selon certaines études
c'est au moins aussi important que
l'aviation voire plus importante là où
c'est intéressant c'est que si vous
voulez l'aviation on culpabilise parce
que c'est l'ouverture à l'autre le
numérique qui est encore une fois une
pratique de leur assurement parce que on
reste chez soi sur son canapé on ne sort
pas de chez soi et ça on en parle
beaucoup moins c'est invisibilisé dans
les problèmes j'ai rencontré des gens
qui travaillent dans le métaver et qui
m'ont fait savoir que donc le métaver
c'est pour permettre de multiplier le
télétravail et j'ai écrit vraiment là
dessus et c'est pour ça que j'ai j'ai
rencontré des gens qui travaillent dans
ce domaine et qui me disait mais nous
nous voulons pour des raisons entre
guillemets écologiques que les gens ne
prennent plus l'avion pour faire des
séminaires de travail et qu'il fasse des
réunions de travail dans le métaver donc
si vous voulez je pense qu'il y a là
aussi quelque chose ou le numérique peut
être un problème pour vous mais on n'en
donne pas en ordonnes mal et les
priorités c'est ça je pense que ce focus
sur l'aviation est un peu suspect
politiquement
suspect politiquement très bien je
voudrais vous ramener au prix alors
c'est peut-être terre à terre mais on
paraît on parlait du Paris New York qui
a permis quand même a beaucoup beaucoup
de monde de découvrir cette cette ville
ça change pas beaucoup on est on a
regardé avec mon équipe aujourd'hui un
Paris-Nice par exemple il est toujours
moins cher en avion qu'en train on va
voir les tarifs et ça c'est d'ailleurs
un peu quel que soit la date de départ
que vous partiez en août ou en octobre
c'est toujours plus intéressant de
prendre un low cost il y a pas de
concurrence je vous rappelle oui
il est déficit du Réseau Ferré de France
et vous savez que les déficits quand
même que c'est normal on gigantesque
on n'a pas parlé d'infrastructure parce
que j'entends le discours de Madame sur
le passerai en Europe etc c'est
formidable parce qu'en Europe on a une
infrastructure très développée de la
route et du chemin de fer mais allez à
les tenir ce discours à des Africains
allez tenir ce discours en Asie même aux
États-Unis il n'y a pas ces
infrastructures il n'y a pas d'autre
choix que l'avion si on va aller un
petit peu plus loin ou alors on prend la
voiture
donc on a un discours aujourd'hui qui
est très centré Europe sans tenir compte
de ces problèmes d'infrastructures et je
viens justement sur la question des
tarifs qu'est-ce qui fait que l'avion
est plus économique c'est que en termes
d'infrastructure il y a pas plus
économique que l'avion vous avez besoin
de 3 km de pistes pour décoller de 3 km
de pistes à l'autre bout et avec ça vous
faites des vols de 5000 km alors qu'un
train il faut une infrastructure tout au
long du train et vous voyez bien que le
moindre orage la moindre innovation ça
vous fiche en l'air le réseau ferré
alors que l'aviation elle est beaucoup
moins sensible et si une des raisons il
y a la question de la concurrence aussi
mais c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
l'avion est moins cher
que le train nécessaire par rapport à ça
c'est un moyen avant de passer à l'avion
vert pour voir un peu comment ça
fonctionne à ne souhaite bon à ce stade
du débat qu'est-ce que ça va vous
inspire quelle question à nos invités
moi j'ai pas de je suis pas du tout
compétente pour parler sur ce sujet mais
ça m'a fait penser en fait bon d'abord à
tous ces questions qu'on entend dans les
meetings politiques puisque moi je l'ai
fait et là il y a je suis un peu
d'accord avec vous quand même la vieille
génération de la nouvelle génération je
trouve que chez les députés on le voit
aussi vous le savez Myriam non mais
après ils ont torts et des petits
enfants entre ils prennent l'avion ils
sont bien contents la question en tout
cas maintenant elle se pose sur le
terrain le doute je vous pose la
question est-ce que vous prenez l'avion
est-ce qu'il faut que je prenne nous on
se pose la question en tant que
journaliste politique mais comme
n'importe quel journaliste par exemple
on a la campagne présidentielle où on
bouge beaucoup on prend l'avion est-ce
qu'il faut qu'on y aille je me souviens
d'un d'un moment où Valérie Pécresse
était allé c'était un déplacement de 7
heures en Martinique donc on avait fait
chez plus 20 heures d'avion aller-retour
parce qu'elle voulait aller dans les
DOM-TOM parce qu'elle avait pas eu le
temps
qui on veut et on défend des bouts de
gras qui sont obsolètes non je crois
quand même qu'en fait
il faut juste comprendre un truc c'est
que plus on attend plus ça va nous
coûter cher plus on attend plus on va
laisser des travailleurs sur le carreau
parce qu'on les a on les aura pas formés
on les aura pas reconvertis alors que
dans la civilisation écologique il y a
plein de secteurs d'avenir qui sont
beaucoup plus sains qui sont beaucoup
plus respectueux et moi je suis pas une
décroissante butée qui dit que l'avion
c'est nul et que le train c'est
formidable d'autres solutions pour vous
juste
enfin c'est s'imposer un peu de rigueur
intellectuelle je pense que tout le
monde a compris qu'il faut un peu faire
les deux essayez de trouver les moyens
de moins consommer l'avion mais en même
temps parier sur cet avion du futur
alors comment ça marche exactement trois
possibilités d'y parvenir les
biocarburants l'hydrogène l'électricité
vous l'avez compris Emmanuel Macron met
de l'argent sur la table 750 millions
d'euros c'est un pari explication
Stéphanie des pierres
l'aéronautique explore trois pistes pour
décarboner la plus sérieuse et la plus
immédiate et celle des carburants verts
ce sont des combustibles à base de
résidus d'algues ou de bois ou d'huile
de friture il y a aussi les carburants
de synthèse qui mixent carbone et
hydrogène l'avantage c'est que les
moteurs actuels peuvent déjà fonctionner
avec 50% de biocarburant sauf qu'on est
même pas capable de produire 1% des
besoins du transport aérien Emmanuel
Macron vient donc d'annoncer 200
millions d'euros pour le développement
de ces carburants verts et la création
d'une usine au pied des Pyrénées seconde
piste l'électricité l'avion électrique
est au point pour des vols très courte
distance et avec quelques passagers
seulement comme pour les taxis volants
en revanche faire voler des longs
courriers uniquement à l'électricité
reste un rêve lointain les batteries
sont trop lourdes et la force de
propulsion de l'électrique bien
insuffisant par rapport au kérosène
enfin dernière piste de l'hydrogène ce
gaz très inflammable tient beaucoup de
place et il est très énergivore Airbus
promet pourtant un avion hydrogène pour
2035 si l'avion vert devient réalité ce
sera plutôt grâce à la combinaison de
ces technologies avec des appareils plus
légers et des moteurs moins gourmands il
y a urgence l'air et rien représente 2 à
3% des émissions de CO2 dans le monde
les compagnies se sont engagées à la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2005 alors
Michel polaco vous connaissez bien le
sujet vous allez aller au Bourget on
peut vraiment faire ce pari de l'avion
vert à zéro émission oui je crois qu'on
peut faire ce pari je pense que c'est un
pari honnête c'est important d'être
honnête c'est à dire de pas vendre du
rêve ou de pas vendre des idées qui sont
irréalisables je crois que c'est un
Paris honnête on sait pas exactement
comment on va y arriver on sait que
c'est une combinaison de plein de choses
dans cette combinaison de plein de
choses il va y avoir l'amélioration des
avions l'amélioration des moteurs
l'amélioration des procédures
d'utilisation des avions 2035 pour
l'avion à hydrogène c'est ambitieux
alors très honnêtement il y aura
peut-être quelques avions alors toute
hydrogène où il y aura peut-être
quelques avions en 2035 mais
certainement pas beaucoup
utilisant de l'hydrogène dans des
catégories d'avions régionaux etc il y
en aura certainement il y en a qui sont
développement actuellement
il y a une entreprise à Toulouse il y a
une compagnie aérienne qui est
recommandée trois avions qui s'appelle
Amélia qui normalement devrait en 2026
arriver à mettre en service des avions
de type ATR ces avions francophones on
est bien positionné la France l'Europe
est bien positionnée avec Airbus
les Anglais les Américains sont tout le
monde travaille un peu là-dessus et on
peut dire qu'en 2035 il y aura
probablement quelques avions régionaux
qui seront capables de voler avec du
zéro émission avec des piles à
combustibles etc
ça à peu près 15% de la flotte globale
mondiale ou 20% de la flotte globale
mondiale d'avion mais si c'est 15 ou 20%
sont passés à des énergies nouvelles
c'est quand même pas négligeable 15 ou
20% dans les 10 ans parce qu'on est
presque en 2025 bon maintenant il est
certain que le pari c'est 200050 c'est
pas 2035 est-ce que Airbus sera capable
de faire voler un avion moyen courrier
parce que un long courrier ça
m'étonnerait il y a du chemin à faire
mais un moyen courrier avec de
l'hydrogène alors je veux dire la
réponse elle est très simple ou bien les
États sont capables de produire
l'électricité nécessaire pour fabriquer
l'hydrogène nécessaire et là c'est
pareil pour les voitures électriques
c'est pareil pour les trains c'est
pareil pour tout le monde ou bien on y
arrivera pas aujourd'hui 98% de
l'hydrogène produit sur terre et produit
à partir du pétrole et du gaz
98%. si on veut produire de l'hydrogène
dans les quantités nécessaires pour les
moyens de transport en général et pour
les énergies en général pour les
bâtiments etc pour avoir de
l'électricité
si vous voulez pour 2050 la solution
la meilleure solution c'est quoi
à partir de biocarburant ou bien de des
carburants totalement de synthèse et qui
nécessiteront beaucoup d'électricité
pour les produire donc de toute façon
quelle que soit la solution on a un
débat électricité électricité énorme
2050 c'est normalement la date à
laquelle la France doit arriver à la
neutralité carbone à ce stade du débat
qui s'achève la tour de verre ça vous
dissuade de prendre quelques avions
superflu d'ici là ou pas
je pense que la question à titre
personnel
j'avais un peu bilan carbone absolument
minuscule à part en effet moi j'aime
beaucoup le principe de l'aviation
mais je pense que derrière
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on reproche à la
mondialisation et à ce modèle entre
guillemets années 80 de la
mondialisation dont je remarque que
l'extrême droite le critique énormément
et que l'écologie le critique pour des
raisons différentes mais qu'est-ce vos
proches est-ce qu'on reproche à la
mondialisation à ce modèle là d'avoir
été producteur d'inégalité entre le Nord
et le Sud je suis entièrement d'accord
d'avoir pollué énormément je suis
entièrement d'accord d'avoir favorisé
aussi parfois des des illusions de
déplacement ça veut dire en effet quand
vous allez dans un club de vacances de
luxe à l'autre bout de la planète vous
ne découvrirez rien de la culture en
question c'est de la fausse
mondialisation est-ce qu'on reproche ça
là je signe si en revanche on reproche à
cette mondialisation là d'avoir fabriqué
des hommes hors sol comme dit à la fois
l'extrême droite et certains écologistes
d'avoir déraciner les gens d'avoir fait
perdre le contact avec la terre avec les
racines avec le sol avec le territoire
alors là je ne signe pas parce que je
pense qu'on s'en prend derrière un
principe politique qui est fondateur de
la démocratie des sociétés ouvertes et
que renoncer à cela quel que soit la
raison quel que soit le commerce de
suicide politique merci beaucoup Nathan
de verre vous aurez le mot de la fin
l'avion à consommer avec modération
est-ce que ça serait une bonne Maxime
pour acheter ce débat oui et puis c'est
surtout prendre conscience vous savez
aujourd'hui la vulgarisation
scientifique c'est un
[Musique]
un travail sur le sujet vous avez des
études sur la sobriété sur les nouveaux
carburants etc merci de ce conseil on
s'arrête là merci à vous merci d'être
venu débattre avec nous sur LCP vous
restez avec moi Anne souhaite mon dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis ce soir le mot de la
semaine de notre sémiologue Mariette
darrhégrand
pourquoi
réindustrialisation n'y reviendra l'écho
avec Fanny Guy nochez sur les prix des
péages cet été attention aux baisse en
trompe-lug et puis d'un Bourbon Express
ce soir de quoi nous parlez-vous Marco
pommier et ben ce soir je vais vous
parler de deux députés à la rescousse de
la réserve parlementaire à tout à
l'heure les amis on plonge d'abord dans
votre podcast à ne souhaite-moi au
lendemain des élections législatives
vous avez eu la bonne idée de demander à
5 députés de tout bord de vous raconter
un peu l'envers du décor cette nouvelle
Assemblée vraiment pas comme les autres
on va le voir à la fois sur le fond mais
aussi sur la forme particulièrement
c'est très réussi des messages vocaux
laissés sur une boucle WhatsApp
qu'est-ce que ça donne on voit ça dans
l'invitation d'Hélène Bonduelle et on en
parle toutes les deux juste après
si on vous invite à me souhaitons c'est
pour une plongée passionnante dans les
coulisses de l'Assemblée nationale une
chronique de l'intérieur d'une année
parlementaire pas comme les autres
journalistes politiques à France Inter
Anne souhaite mon vous êtes l'auteur du
podcast député le principe une boucle
WhatsApp et des messages audio échangés
pendant 8 mois entre 5 députés de bord
différents alors c'est Benjamin on est
le dimanche bonsoir c'est Julien nous
sommes le mercredi
Clémentine je viens d'entendre le
message de Julien 2h51
[Musique]
52 sans majorité absolue les jeux sont
plus ouverts un retour de hype de
l'Assemblée dites-vous et du rôle de
députés qui partagent ici leur victoire
et leurs défaites ce soir je vais me
coucher très content et ravi on a gagné
pas mal d'amendements donc c'est bien
généralement quand il y a elle fait une
audio pour dire que qu'elle fasse
coucher très contente par définition ça
veut dire que qu'il y en a qui le sont
un peu moins effectivement on en a pris
une belle paume ce soir
salut on y découvre aussi le rythme
effréné des parlementaires entre les
séances parisiennes et le travail en
circonscription Clémentine je suis dans
ma voiture j'ai fait un aller-retour
chez moi pour faire à manger à mes
enfants voilà et
là je repars parce qu'on est fait c'est
un moment assez important
bonsoir c'est Julien il est 20h22 et en
fait je réagis parce que je viens
d'écouter le message de clémentine je
n'avais même situation j'essaie de jeudi
c'est ma mission aussi c'est
l'organisation pour pour les enfants
c'est moi qui m'y colle et je suis en
train d'en faire une omelette dans ce
podcast comme dans l'hémicycle les
moments de crispation vont s'intensifier
avec les débats ou le sur la réforme des
retraites et la multiplication des 49,3
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous c'est
Benjamin j'ai un peu perdu toute notion
du temps je m'amuse quand même de
constater que ce gouvernement est très
écolo contrairement à ce qu'on dit
puisqu'il pratique un art du recyclage
des 49-3 voilà
[Musique]
bon black mise à part on est quand même
dans un dans un triste moment pour pour
notre démocratie et je ne sais pas
comment on va sortir de tout ça en fait
là j'en ai marre parce qu'on se dit mais
merde on sacrifie on bosse on s'acharne
on défend les Français et peu importe
l'étiquette politique là tout à tout
moment peut être tout ce qu'on a fait va
être balayé d'un revers de main et
franchement c'est c'est fatigant de voir
que le gouvernement s'amuse de nous
en suivant au plus près le travail
parlementaire vous avez donc tenté de
capter la sincérité des députés alors
Anne souhaite mon nous avons une
question votre podcast peut-il
réconcilier les Français avec la
politique
réponse à ne souhaite non j'aimerais
bien j'aimerais bien c'est aussi pour ça
pour sortir un peu de la défiance que
vous l'avez fait ouais mais en fait ça
fait 10 ans que je suis journaliste
politique donc ça fait 6 ans que je
repente les meetings je les déplacements
avec peu les ministres plutôt les
députés les responsables politiques j'ai
beaucoup couvert le RN j'ai vu beaucoup
de Français en colère mais qui
s'intéressaient à la politique et je
trouve que en fait la l'image qu'on les
hommes et les femmes politiques les
députés notamment
et pas très réel c'est à dire que on a
l'impression qu'ils sont déconnectés ils
passent leur vie on le voit dans le
podcast sur le terrain ils vont dans les
commémorations ils discutent avec des
gens on a l'impression qu'ils nous les
messages sont postés entre minuit et 3h
du matin ils ont travaillé cette année
je crois que c'est historique en volume
vraiment très très tard beaucoup
beaucoup de loi et tout on les dit
déconnecté de la réalité ils sont quand
même en train de créer la France de
demain enfin je veux dire c'est eux qui
font les lois ils sont techniques dans
les commissions certains ont parlé dans
le débat juste avant de l'avion sur les
énergies renouvelables pierre qui est
dans le podcast a été l'un de ceux qui a
porté le texte
technique il connaît super bien ce sont
d'ailleurs disputés avec Benjamin il y a
ce je trouve ce hiatus entre l'image
qu'on a de ces gens et ce qu'ils sont
réellement et j'avais un petit peu envie
mon petit mon petit cadeau de fin de
journée politique de réhabiliter cette
image là après j'en pense aussi la
colère de certains Français vous
comprenez tout de suite que l'assemblée
va redevenir d'une certaine façon le
centre de la vie politique vous dites
qu'il y a un retour de de hype comment
vous vient l'idée tout de suite de se
dire tiens je vais je vais essayer de
convaincre quelques députés différentes
se confier de façon un peu intime parce
que c'est ça le répondeur le message
vocal comment ça ça se décide tout ça
alors je pourrais plus vous dire
exactement comment on a eu l'image du le
enfin l'idée du du message WhatsApp mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que dès qu'il y a
eu les élections l'année dernière donc
il y a un an et qu'on a su qu'il y avait
pas de majorité absolue on s'est dit à
France Inter il faut absolument qu'on
réussisse à raconter cette assemblée il
va s'y passer des choses qui ne se passe
plus depuis des années on se souvient la
dernière législature on parlait de
députés godillot il y avait jamais de
surprise très très et là on savait que
ça allait avoir lieu juillet loi pouvoir
d'achat plein de surprises des choses
passent les députés retrouvent nous on
les croise les journalistes politiques
on voyait qu'il y avait une sorte
d'enthousiasme et tout ça donc on s'est
dit quelle forme on va trouver et
effectivement moi je voulais essayer de
pas tomber dans le truc trop pédago trop
classique parce que ça aussi ça ennuie
un peu les Français pour les ramener
vers le politique il fallait trouver un
peu un nouveau format et on a eu l'idée
de ces notes WhatsApp parce que les
députés ils sont tout le temps sur leur
téléphone dans l'hémicycle ils sont sur
télégram sur WhatsApp certains
s'envoient des messages vocaux et donc
on s'est dit ben voilà ça pourrait être
ça marche très bien d'ailleurs parce
qu'il y a autant une adresse aux autres
qu'un peu à soi-même il y a presque
quelque chose d'un peu du confessionnal
par moment pourquoi eux pourquoi les
avoir choisi eux Clémentine Autain et
les filles pierre Cazeneuve Renaissance
Julien diweller Benjamin Lucas écolo et
il y a le ménage à Rennes alors moi je
couvre la droite donc je connaissais
déjà très bien Julien dive donc en fait
j'ai un peu commencé avec ce que ce que
je connaissais donc je suis allé voir
Julien dive et au début j'ai jaugé
est-ce que c'était le second mandat
connaissez la boutique le troisième en
fait il a eu il a fait une élection
partielle mais effectivement il est il a
roulé sa bosse il connaît bien les
arcanes de l'Assemblée pour jauger un
peu est-ce que eux ça ça les intéressait
et est-ce qu'ils allaient accepter de se
prêter au jeu parce que j'en étais pas
sûr ça demande quand même une forme
d'engagement sur plusieurs mois de se
dire vous les rappeler à l'ordre revenez
nous parler ça revient souvent coucou
c'est
il va falloir nous dire des choses sans
réponse j'en ai plein et puis bon bah
j'ai vu que ça a fonctionné donc après
j'ai essayé d'avoir quelque chose en
plateau un petit peu représentatif des
équilibre donc je me suis dit bah il
faut forcément quelqu'un Renaissance
donc là pour être tout à fait honnête
c'est un collaborateur ministériel que
je connaissais qui m'a dit ah mais il y
a un nouveau député Pierre cannelle
Cazeneuve qui m'a fait rencontrer donc
ça s'est fait un peu comme ça je me suis
dit évidemment
eren premier groupe d'opposition c'était
historique en juin ils sont rentrés avec
89 députés aujourd'hui 88 et il y a le
ménage je ne la connaissais pas ça s'est
fait autour d'un café comme ça
Clémentine évidemment figure beaucoup
plus connue beaucoup plus à un jeu très
très politique elle a accepté alors que
j'ai eu quand même un certain nombre de
refus on sent que voilà il a fallu
parfois les faire un peu revenir dans
dans le projet ce qui ce qui frappe
c'est la pédagogie il y a un énorme
boulot quand même d'ailleurs on le voit
bien les Français depuis la crise des
retraites se sont emparés de leur
constitution car nous F3 on a découvert
plein d'articles nous aussi c'est vrai
les journalistes l'article 40 par
exemple il fallait s'y replonger il y a
un besoin d'explication vous avez senti
une soif de comprendre oui bah je trouve
d'abord parce que effectivement nous on
a dû se plonger beaucoup plus
précisément dans des moments
parlementaires alors il y a du jargon
mais il y a aussi de la technique il y a
beaucoup de mécanique par exemple moi ce
qui m'avait frappé c'est les niches qui
sont devenues des journées hyper
importantes alors vous sur LCP
évidemment vous connaissiez déjà c'est
vrai que dans un média comme France
Inter bon les niches on en parlait assez
peu en général ça passait jamais et là
une journée consacrée aux initiatives
d'un groupe parlementaire maintenant il
y a des choses qui passent et ça je me
suis dit il faut absolument que j'en
parle parce qu'en fait ils en parlaient
tout le temps mais fallait que
j'explique donc effectivement il y a eu
pas mal il y a des petits moments pédago
un peu la constitution ou le règlement
de l'Assemblée pour les nuls parce qu'en
fait c'est hyper important à raconter la
mécanique du 49-3 en fait comment est-ce
qu'on arrive au 49-3 le fait qu'il soit
frustré non seulement parce que le débat
s'arrête mais aussi parce que les
amendements qui ont été votés peuvent ne
pas être retenus ça paraît un peu
différent pour un Français enthousiasme
les moment s désillusion aussi et puis
il y a des gros coups de gueule on va
écouter
et que tu le veuilles ou non nous avons
été élus comme toi au même titre que toi
et j'aimerais bien que tu le respectes
que tu respectes la démocratie que tu
respectes le bulletin de vote et que tu
respectes les Français ce serait bien
d'accord moi ici j'ai été élu dans ma
circonscription à plus de 61 % que ça te
plaise ou non ils ont voté contre la
nupesse d'accord mais c'est sûr que
travailler avec des gens comme vous
sectaire qui ont voté pour Emmanuel
Macron dont le seul le seul le seul
point de son programme c'était la
réforme des retraites et ensuite aller
se plaindre de la réforme des retraites
alors que vous avez voté pour lui c'est
un peu du foutage de gueule voilà elle
vit de son sac et elle menace et le jour
là elle le fait plusieurs fois il est
important ce coup de gueule parce qu'il
en dit long sur les relations notamment
entre la gauche la nupesse et le RN ils
en ont marre et les députés ARN d'être
ostracisés on peut dire ça je pense
qu'ils ont cru au début par exemple en
faisant ce podcast je pense que Yaël a
dû se dire ah chouette on propose
peut-être un espace où je vais pouvoir
je suis dans la bande je suis dans la
bande et je suis une députée comme les
autres je pense qu'ils ont cru à ça et
effectivement c'est ce que je monte dans
l'épisode 2 on voit bien que il y a
plusieurs choses d'abord rien de passe
en fait il ne passe aucun texte des
amendements c'est rarissime et puis
ensuite parce que on ne leur paste rien
non plus la nupaisse dès que il y a elle
raconte quelque chose vous avez Benjamin
l'écologie ou Clémentine Autain
insoumise qui répondent en disant on
n'est pas d'accord on a un problème à
parler avec l'extrême droite mais je
trouve qu'il faut quand même le dire
certes il y a ces gros coup de gueule et
ça a été compliqué enfin je veux dire
clémentine et Yaël ne se sont pas
beaucoup parlés frontalement mais le
jour où on a lancé le podcast on s'est
retrouvé au Bourbon c'est pas loin d'ici
un café où il y a tous les députés elles
étaient à la même table et j'ai un
collègue qui m'a dit envoyer un message
en disant qu'est-ce que c'est que ton
groupe de Yalta et on a réussi aussi
plusieurs fois dans l'année elle les
mettent dans le même bureau et en fait
là il y avait de l'humain je me souviens
un moment on a parlé de leurs enfants et
ça c'était voilà politiquement ça
pouvait pas matcher ce sont des
militants avant tout mais ce sont aussi
des hommes et des femmes et parfois ils
arrivent quand même à se parler parce
que vous les appelez plus que par leur
prénom et oui je finis par travers les
connaître
vous vous appelez Anne vous les tutoyez
non non pas vraiment non moi j'ai tutoie
pas entre j'ai accepté la règle du
prénom parce qu'en fait eux ce sont
appelés par leur prénom je trouvais ça
bizarre de dire Clémentine Autain alors
que les autres l'appelaient Clémentine
par contre eux ce tutoie c'est un peu
une sorte de règle entre entre députés
et ça j'ai voulu garder cette distance
moi je ne les ai jamais tutoyé certains
ont quitté l'aventure en cours de route
pourquoi
49,3 sur les retraites ça a été immédiat
49-3 sur les retraites on va pas dire
qui pour donner
à la réforme et qui voulait voter et
outré par l'usage du 49-3 du
gouvernement mais aussi par la manière
dont d'autres groupes que le sien se
sont se sont opposés et du coup d'abord
coup seul message assez froid mais très
très dur et demi plus tard je vois dans
le gros WhatsApp
XX je peux pas dire le prénom à quitter
le groupe et là c'est effectivement l'un
des tournois du podcast et un an après
c'est ma dernière question qu'avez-vous
appris deux est-ce que votre regard a
changé sur le travail de député un
traitement oui alors je pense que même
moi alors que c'est mon travail je ne me
rendais pas compte de la disponibilité
que ça que ça demande moi je dois dire
un immense respect pour les
parlementaires
je j'ai découvert aussi des hommes et
des femmes que j'ai appris à bien aimer
c'est vrai que ça change d'avoir un
espace comme ça pendant des mois et des
mois et je me suis demandé même si ça
réconciliait réconcilier pas un petit
peu les politiques avec le journaliste
politique parce que c'est vrai que
parfois ça peut être un peu tendu ça
peut être un peu tendu vous le savez
mieux que mieux que quiconque et ça je
pense qu'on a réussi à créer un petit
collectif sympa quand même merci
beaucoup ça s'appelle député au pluriel
c'est gratuit ça se télécharge d'un clic
c'est un podcast original de France
Inter courésie vous restez avec moi on
passe aux affranchis leur parti pris
pour vous faire réagir on les accueille
tout de suite
de France Info Mariette dari grand pour
le mot de la semaine préparez vos cartes
blanches on commence comme chaque soir
par le bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nationale nous est
raconté ce soir par Marco Polo bonsoir
Marco bonsoir Myriam ce soir je vous
raconte l'histoire de deux députés à la
rescousse de la réserve parlementaire
késako et ben vous savez c'est ce
dispositif supprimé en 2017 par la
majorité macroniste au nom de la
confiance dans la vie publique ça
permettait au parlementaire et bien
d'aider financièrement les communes ou
les associations dans leur
circonscription à chaque parlementaire
disposait d'une enveloppe d'une
enveloppe annuelle de 130 000 euros
environ 6 ans plus tard offensive de 140
députés ils en appel au retour de cette
réserve parlementaire c'est l'objectif
de la proposition de loi déposée par
André Villiers député horizon et
dinosineries des républicains vous le
voyez parmi ceux qui soutiennent
l'initiative à des députés macronistes
qui avaient pourtant voté la suppression
de la en 2017 autre élu lui aussi de la
majorité qui rêve de rétablir le
dispositif car l'olive écoutez
un petit village qui s'appelle
Flexanville j'ai été samedi fête du
village ils sont en train tout court
avec leur barnum
le barnum il aurait pu être
effectivement
financé par la réserve parlementaire
c'est pas du clientélisme tout ça doit
être encadré mais c'est ce qui permet de
renouer le tissu avec avec le terrain
vous l'avez entendu Myriam c'est pas du
clientélisme c'était pourtant l'un des
reproches formulées contre la réserve
parlementaire en 2017 trop d'opacité
disait-on aussi et c'est vrai qu'il y a
eu des dérives André Villiers-le
reconnaît mais le député de la majorité
a une autre théorie sur la suppression
du dispositif en 2017 la nouvelle
législature a fait apparaître un grand
nombre de députés nouveaux qui n'avaient
pas ce regard sur l'antériorité sur le
fonctionnement du Parlement et notamment
sur le lien qui existe entre
le parlementaires en l'occurrence un
député et son territoire donc je crois
que ça a été là la source sans aucun
doute qui a scellé le sort de la réserve
parlementaire j'imagine que si elle
revenait ce qui n'est pas fait ce serait
pas tout à fait la même réserve non il y
aurait des conditions
quand même voulu prendre en compte dans
leur propositions de loi les demandes
d'encadrement il propose par exemple que
seuls les communes de moins de 18000
habitants et les associations puissent
bénéficier de cette réserve
parlementaire autre proposition pour
plus de transparence rendre public les
bénéficiaires du dispositif et les
montants à louer pas suffisants pour
certains élus ça ne change rien donc
après une fois que vous avez publié la
liste des bénéficiaires ça veut pas dire
que vous avez pas privilégiez vos
copains par rapport aux autres donc ça
ça ne sert strictement à rien est-ce que
vous pensez pas que cette réserve
parlementaire elle pourrait justement
remettre du lien entre les territoires
et leur parlementaires mais non ça c'est
des faux prétexte si vous voulez du lien
avec votre territoire vous y allez sur
le territoire c'est tout c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça c'est pas coup de
chéquier ou de chèques en blanc vous
créez un lien voilà député du MoDem bon
elle a aucune chance de revenir
finalement si j'entends ce député en
tout cas on en est loin pour l'instant
de révilier et d'innocinéi il milite
pour que leur proposition loi soit
inscrite à l'agenda de l'Assemblée lors
d'une semaine réservée au texte
transpartisans ils ont même rencontré la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale qui
reste prudente sur le sujet aux
dernières nouvelles elle est ouverte au
dialogue dit-on rappelons quand même que
c'est yelbron pivée en 2017 qui portait
le texte sur la suppression de la
réserve parlementaire
en ces temps de polémique sur le fond
Marianne pas sûr que les Français soient
convaincus par l'idée mais qui sait on
suivra ça avec vous Marco alors on
enchaîne avec vous Fanny ce soir vous
vouliez nous parler de de ces baisses de
prix au péage qu'on nous promet pour cet
été
c'est raté finalement non c'est un peu
en trompe l'oeil parce que c'est baisse
de compris n'ont rien à voir ce sont des
ristournes toutes les compagnies vont le
faire elles n'ont rien à voir avec des
baisses de prix comme on a pu connaître
par exemple dans les stations services
alors pour ne pas citer mais par exemple
total faisait une ristourne sur le
carburant vous alliez à la pompe et vous
n'aviez rien à vous aviez pas à montrer
pas de Blanche là pour bénéficier des
ristournes que propose SANEF ou encore
Vinci ou Eiffage et bien il faut prendre
des systèmes de télépéage donc ça veut
dire finalement prendre un système de
fidélisation d'abonnement il y a une
partie de ces questions ça dépend des
offres je rentre pas dans les détails
mais qui sont faites quand vous abondez
votre système de télépéage en
chèques-vacances tous les Français n'ont
pas des chèques-vacances donc vous voyez
c'est quand même très contraignant très
restrictif et ça n'est pas la première
fois que les compagnies d'autoroute les
sociétés d'autoroute font
ce système ce geste l'année dernière
elles avaient procédé exactement de la
même façon le gouvernement pourtant mais
la pression sur justement pour ça
qu'elle soit un geste pour dire regardez
on fait quelque chose et c'est vrai que
le gouvernement leur met la pression
parce que il leur demande depuis
plusieurs mois de modérer les tarifs la
hausse des tarifs des péages c'est en
février qu'elles tombent et c'était 5%
4,75 cette année c'est à peu près le
niveau de l'inflation un peu moins mais
mais quand même avec un budget des
automobilistes qui est extrêmement
contraint du fait du prix des carburants
on pouvait se dire que les sociétés
d'autoroute pouvaient faire un effort
d'autant plus qu'il y a eu un rapport
qui a transmis Bercy qui montre que
cette année elles ont fait des supers
profits et que elles ont donc engrangé
beaucoup d'argent et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement n'exclut pas d'aller
piocher une partie de ce pactole pour
financer la transition écologique et
notamment le gouvernement vous le savez
promette de mettre 100 milliards d'euros
pour financer le train bah ça pourrait
permettre d'aller prendre un peu
l'argent de ce côté là donc tout ça ne
va pas améliorer l'image des sociétés
d'autoroute et bien non quand vous
faites un petit constat autour de vous
on se rend compte que les sociétés
d'autoroute elles ne sont pas bonnes
presse il faut dire que depuis
l'histoire de la priv ça fait très
longtemps que ça ouvre toutes les
polémiques lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle un certain nombre de
candidats étaient pour une
renationalisation mais en fait ça n'est
pas si simple parce que ce sont des
contrats que l'État à passer avec ses
concessions c'est des contrats sur le
long terme mais si on voulait
renationaliser ça veut dire que Bercy
devrait payer de l'argent ça se chiffre
en millions milliard même d'euros donc
on en a pas forcément les moyens et puis
la question c'est de dire est-ce que
l'État meilleur gestionnaire ou pas
est-ce qu'on aurait des routes qui
seraient aussi bien entretenues si ça
repassait dans son escarcelle quoi qu'il
en soit dans ce contexte c'est vrai
qu'on peut se dire que c'est un peu
décevant la façon dont les sociétés
d'autoroute font un petit geste il faut
rappeler quand même qu'en France quatre
Français sur 10 ne partent pas en
vacances pour une raison toute simple
des questions économiques merci beaucoup
Fanny j'espère que cette chronique fera
un petit peu avancée leurs causes
espérer allez on enchaîne avec le mot de
la semaine pour terminer ré
industrialisation c'est pas mal cogner
nous les sur ce mot vous l'avez choisi
parce que il ne vous laisse pas
indifférent oui bah absolument on l'a
beaucoup entendu c'est quand même un
sujet énorme mais en fait ce qui
m'intéresse dans le mot c'est son
préfixe ils sont
parce que nous vivons dans une époque de
rock que ce soit la reconnexion avec la
nature là on a entendu la reconquête du
tissu social la relocalisation des
usines et les préfixes sont toujours des
très très bons indicateurs idéologiques
donc notre époque elle adore les
préfixes elle adore le trans la
transition le D comme décarbonation mais
en fait son préféré je crois en ce
moment
du réencrage qui nous remet dans les
dans les pas de notre histoire que ce
soit résilience réhabilitation voilà
qu'il y en a énormément il y en a
énormément
peut-être alors quel sens il a se re
c'est un retour alors ça c'est ça est-ce
qu'il a un sens de régression de retour
je crois qu'il y a deux rues en fait il
y a l'heureux vintage et il y a le
une chaleur le vintage en effet c'est un
retour peut-être à une France heureuse à
une France de la l'industrie très forte
du mettons de concorde d'Ariane pourquoi
pas du militaire donc en effet ça nous
fait revenir à quelque chose on n'est
pas très très loin de la logique de
Trump quand il avait dit le retour de la
grandeur américaine et d'ailleurs Biden
continuent à le faire c'est toujours la
même logique je crois que reprendre le
contrôle reprendre le contrôle il a
repris aux États-Unis il y a toujours
cette réduction de ce plan de réduction
de l'inflation pour que les industries
reviennent sur le sol américain pourquoi
pas nous après tout un peu de Cocorico
ne nuit pas et puis on a des bons
ingénieurs des bons capitaines
d'industrie donc nous pouvons
effectivement réactiver quelque chose de
notre tradition industrielle mais dans
le réindustrialisation là c'est vrai que
ça veut dire quoi on peut faire de
l'écologie et de la politique
industrielle c'est ça le hic c'est ça la
grande question Myriam effectivement
parce que là il y a un deuxième le
deuxième re qui lui est niage revient
arrive et ben c'est il nous reconnecte à
la nature ils nous relie au vivant et
puis probablement il nous demande aussi
de réduire quelque chose de notre
consommation donc harmoniser ces deux
rues c'est le gros sujet politique du
siècle bon donc on est vraiment là
dessus alors de temps en temps il y a un
troisième requie arrive un rôle du
troisième type il y en a eu cette
semaine qui m'a sauté aux yeux au plus
tôt aux oreilles parce que j'ai entendu
ça à la radio c'est le rôle de
Réparation d'autres choses et c'était à
propos d'une société française une PME
qui est en plein succès parce que
figurez-vous que la trouver une très
bonne idée elle est située à Roissy elle
répare les valises à roulettes des
voyageurs oui j'ai entendu ce sujet
formidable idée parce que la réparation
c'est plus qu'une bonne idée c'est un
concept aujourd'hui de production donc
réparer nos objets d'électroménager
réparer les vélos réparer les vêtements
peut-être réparer aussi les corps si on
veut devenir centenaire donc c'est un
vrai concept tout à fait intéressant
mais je dois dire pour finir bien que
j'ai retenu cette anecdote parce que
l'histoire des valises à roulettes je
l'avais déjà en tête à cause d'un livre
génial que vous avez peut-être lu il y a
une dizaine d'années une quinzaine
d'années c'est le signe noir de Nicolas
Nassim Taleb qui est un personnage très
curieux qui travaille justement sur les
modèles industriels et sur le programme
et ce monsieur avait dit c'est quand
même très curieux c'est toujours baroque
l'innovation c'est curieux l'homme est
allé sur la Lune avant d'avoir inventé
la machine à rouler la valise à roulette
et c'est formidable je trouve que c'est
une très belle leçon d'humanité sur
l'intelligence et l'ingéniosité humaine
et aussi je crois une belle leçon
d'humilité industrielle bon alors au
revoir merci
merci c'était passionnant comme chaque
semaine ce vendredi itinéraires d'un mot
avec Mariette darrigan merci Fanny et à
très vite Marco très bon week-end et
merci à
allez c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à la rédaction merci à la
production à la régie et à l'équipe qui
m'accompagne au quotidien c'est le
weekend profitez bien à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]